in this video we are going to talk about
databases when you're dealing with
backend systems interacting and handling
databases is one of the most important
and one of the most frequent operation
that you're going to perform so
understanding all the concepts
surrounding it is crucial to be
efficient in your job so let's start
with the question why why do we need
databases in the first place now at its
core a database is simp simply a way to
persist information across different
different sessions to talk in a very
high level and what that means is and
persistence basically means storing data
in a way so that it survives even after
the program that created it has been
stopped so for example think of your
to-do list app right you add an entry
and you can check off all the task that
you have already finished etc etc like
that's the basic functionality and
expectation from a to-do app now when
you do some operation when you create an
item or you when check off an item and
you close the app and when you open it
again you find all the information the
state of the data that you left it it's
the same when you visit again when you
come back to the app so that's what we
mean when you say persistence the
information has to be there in the same
expected
State even after a considerable amount
of time has passed or across different
different physical locations right
that's what we mean by persistence if
you did not have persistence every time
you open that app You' have to create
new to-do list items and You' lose all
your progress whatever task you had
created previously etc etc right
persistence is a very important thing
and we use it in our day-to-day lives a
lot now what is a database when what do
we mean
when we say the word database the term
database is surprisingly very very Broad
in the simplest sense any kind of
structured any kind of structured
storage can be considered as a database
for example you have a smartphone and in
your phone you have a contact list right
of different different people and that
list can be considered as a database
in the same way if you are a developer
you must be familiar with the concept of
local storage uh which is offered by
every browser so we can check that out
right now if we open this the developer
tools and when we go application and we
can check the local storage and it has
some entries right since we are using
this website called xcal draw the
website has stored some entries in the
format of key Value Store it also has a
session storage also has a cookie
storage etc etc right all these
different different types of storage
mechanisms they are also considered as a
database and even if you take a simple
text file where you just jot down notes
and you can refer to those notes later
on even that can be considered as a very
very basic database so if you try to
derive the patterns from all these
examples database basically means
is some kind of system some kind of
persistent system which offers ways to
create read update and delete data from
it right that's a very basic and high
level example of database which is not
limited to what we mean when we say
database in the context of backend
systems database is a very generic term
which means a persistence layer which
provides operations of crud create read
delete and update but when we say
database in the context of backend
systems in the context of servers right
in typical developer context when we
mention database there what we mean is
disk based databases disk based right
and by dis I mean hard disk it can be
HDD ssds or whatever modern technology
of storage we have available but why dis
storage why dis based databases because
disk storage whether it's a traditional
hard drive or a modern solid state drive
or also known as SSD is relatively cheap
when compared to other means of storage
for example when we consider Ram which
is also considered as a main memory or
the primary memory when we take into
account our CPU unit right if you're
from a computer science background you
must have known that we have a CPU unit
which can access the primary memory and
it can also access the secondary memory
which we also call as dis based memory
right which uses either a hard drive or
a SSD now Ram is very fast it's called
main memory and it is very very fast as
compared to the dis based alternative
but the problem is Ram based storage
it's relatively costly and we don't have
as much Supply as you do when it comes
to dis based so if you check the
configuration of your system whether it
is a Windows Bas Linux Mac does not
matter if you check the configuration of
your system most people have something
like 8 GB Ram or 16 GB Ram or 32 GB Ram
or if you are on the higher end of the
consumer you must be having 64 or Max to
Max 128 GB of RAM right but when it
comes to hard disk when it comes to a
second disc storage most people since
hard discs are relatively cheap these
days most people they have storage
starting from 5 12 GB up to 2 TB right
that's the average storage people have
in their laptops in their systems right
and you can see the pattern we when it
comes to the storage space we have
limited amount of ram we have limited
amount of primary memory but we have a
lot of space when it comes to displaced
memory or secondary memory and trade off
is RAM is very fast when it comes to
data retrieval or data saving and disk
based storage is relatively slow because
of the way the data is stored and
because of the way the data is fetched
and that's the reason when we use
caching mechanisms either in redis or in
memory caches etc etc whenever we talk
about caching we talk about storage in
Ram or storage in primary memory
because fetching data or saving data
from primary memory from our cache is
very very fast when it comes to fetching
data from our databases which are disk
based storages also known as secondary
storage but when it comes to databases
the thing that matters most is we need
more space and we can do a fair amount
of tradeoff when it comes to speed and
that's the reason most databases at
least when it comes to traditional
databases like relational or non-
relational databases they are based on
disk based storage or secondary storage
that's where they actually store the
data and the format they store the data
the way they store their data all the
algorithm surrounding it etc etc that's
a very technically deep area and we are
not going to cover that in this video we
just want to keep this relevant for a
backend engineer right on the
application Level the only thing you
need to know is
caching Technologies like redis Etc they
store their data in primary memory or
RAM and databases traditional databases
like POG or mongod Debi which we'll
cover next all these relational or non-
relational databases they store their
data in disk or secondary memory because
disk based storages offer more capacity
at less price but at the cost of less
speed that it is clear we are talking
about databases in the context of disk
based storage and that too in the
context of backend systems right now we
come to a term which is known as dbms
also known as database management system
now what is a database management system
just storing our data whatever data we
have just storing it in some kind of dis
based storage that is not enough of
course we also need different different
ways of retrieving that data or making
changes to that data or deleting that
data right all these different different
operations that has to be done and that
has to be done in a very efficient way
since we are talking about hundreds and
thousands of GBS of data right so we
need these operations create read update
and delete operations and that to in a
very efficient manner and that's the
reason we have softwares we have
software systems
called as dbms softwares and whose sole
responsibility is to efficiently provide
all these cud operations to this to the
clients or to the users whoever is using
it and storing that data of course they
also have a lot of other
responsibilities like security and
scaling the database systems and load
balancing etc etc right but on a very
high level they have two
responsibilities storing the data and
providing different different operations
to the client or the user primarily CED
operations create read update and delete
so in a way some of the responsibilities
of dbms that we can point out is First
Data organization they need to
efficiently organize the data so that
fetching updating and creating more data
etc etc all these operations are
efficient second access as I've already
mentioned they have to provide methods
to do c operations create read update
and delete third Integrity now it's a
technical term but what it basically
means is the accuracy of the data the
validity of the data we'll see what all
these different different buzzwords mean
when we actually go into examples so
this just means the data is correct
right whatever data that we are storing
that data is valid that data is not
corrupt so to give you a very high level
example it's an e-commerce platform and
we want to store all the order details
of customers and each order will have
some kind of payment information how
much was the order etc etc right and in
the database we are storing the payment
amount as a number so it's the
responsibility of our database
management system or our dbms software
to maintain the Integrity of the data so
that no one can insert anything in that
field if we have a payment field then
for this field we want only number data
Ty right we want some kind of numerical
amount so someone if someone tries to
store a string something like let's say
something and if they try to insert it
here that should fail the dbms software
should not allow it because it's their
responsibility to maintain the Integrity
of the data the correctness of the data
the validity of the data right it has a
lot of meanings in a lot of contexts but
this is what it means the data has to be
accurate the data has to be consistent
now fourth is security which basically
means protecting the data from
unauthorized access databases dbm
softwares have different different users
different different roles etc etc for
the sake of protecting the access to
data right so that's a very high level
overview of what are the different
responsibilities of database management
system now here we have a question why
do we need these dbms softwares why not
use just simple text files or any kind
of file and store all our data in text
format inside it and when people were
coming up with these concepts of
databases or before people came up with
these concepts of database management
system this is how people started with
they try to store all the data in text
files right now the problem with storing
your data in text files is there are a
couple of problems first thing parsing
so if we are going to store our data in
a text file every time you wanted to
find a specific data point let's say
it's a customer database and you are
storing all the details of your customer
in your database inside that text file
as plain text and every time you want to
find a specific customer you'd have to
write code application code it it can be
any programming language python Java
JavaScript go rust it can be any
programming language you have to write
code in that programming language in
your application Level in your backend
code to pass the text file split the
lines so if we have a text file and we
have different different lines you have
to pass all the entries of this text
file and we have to split these lines
and we have to compare each field and
this whole process is very slow if
you're familiar with passing data from
our file system in different different
programming languages languages like
rust are relatively faster when it comes
to passing kind of uh operations but
languages like JavaScript python are
relatively slower as compared to rust
right they are fast but compared to a
highly performing language like rust
they are relatively slow so if you're
programming language is something like
JavaScript or Ruby then you'll also face
a huge performance
hit right and also doing all this
passsing thing is very error prone if
something goes wrong you can corrupt
your data you can provide wrong
information to your customers etc etc
like parsing itself is not an efficient
solution because how slow the operation
is and how error prone it is the second
thing is there is no structure text
files do not have a formal structure you
cannot enforce that data has to be in
this particular structure in this file
right text files are very fluid you can
store any amount of text in any format
you just have to dump it there right
there is no structure and that makes it
very difficult to enforce consistency in
data you cannot enforce something like
this particular field will only have
number you cannot enforce that rule
right since it is all text file since it
is all string it will take any kind of
data and it will put it there right it
cannot promise any kind of data
consistency third thing concurrency by
concurrency what we mean what happens if
two people at the same time try to
update the same taex value right whose
update is going to be considered as
legit and whose update is going to be
going to get discarded obviously the
last one who updated this text file only
their update is going to persist because
let's say we have a text file and we
have an entry let's say amount right
amount and we have something like 40 two
people are trying to access it for the
sake of modification they want to modify
this field called amount so the first
thing they will do obviously is read the
file right they need to read the file
before they make any changes they cannot
just put some arbitary amount they want
to increase the amount so one person
wants to increase the amount by 20
another person wants to to decrease the
amount by 20 now what happens both of
them read the data right both of them
read the data at the same time they
start their operation at the same time
okay they both have the initial entry of
40 so the first person they increase the
amount so they do 60 and the second
person they want to decrease the amount
so they do it 20 and they save it now
even though both of them started at the
same time because it was a read
operation when they save it of course
there is going to be some kind of first
comes first Ser kind of situation you
cannot tell beforehand that this update
is going to persist or this update is
going to persist it all depends on what
CPU cycle it is running and and thousand
different parameters right so depending
on the environment of the system at the
end of this operation at the end of both
of these operations the value it might
be 60 or it might be 20 right there is
no consistency here that's what you mean
by concurrency when two different users
try to do some kind of modification at
the same time to the same data you need
some kind of concurrency mechanisms
inside that software inside that
database software to efficiently to
accurately manage the whole interactions
to provide a consistent result right and
a simple text file simply cannot do that
so these are overall all the the
challenges that people faced and if you
try to do that today you'll also face
the same challenges after some time
after your data Grows Right and because
of all these challenges because of all
these limitations of Simply storing your
database in a text file people came up
with softwares like dbms and now that we
are talking about dbms we have finally
reached the stage where we can talk
about different types of dbms software
on a very high level we have two types
the major two types one is relational
and the other is the opposite non-
relational relational database basically
means a database system which organizes
data in
tables rows and columns okay and
relationships between different
different tables are defined using
Concepts like foreign key Etc right so
of the key features of relational
databases data is
structured and data is inserted into a
database which have predefined
predefined schema you cannot just
arbitrarily insert or push any kind of
data into your database that particular
data should have a particular schema
which basically means it should have a
corresponding table and that table will
have a very strict schema you have to
beforehand Define All The Columns of a
table and all the data types of those
columns right everything has to be pred
decided you cannot do anything on the
flat it is a very strict system and
because of that strict schema enforcing
the advantage it offers is data
Integrity which basically means at any
point of time you can bet on the state
of your data you know what is the data
type of a particular column is what are
the different relationships between
different different tables and a lot of
different things the data in your tables
always have a consistent State they'll
always have an accurate State similarly
we have non- relational of and next in
order to interact with this database we
generally use the language SQL also
known as structured query language in
the same way we have non- relational
databases so some examples of relational
databases which you might have already
heard MySQL postgress SQL Server etc etc
right we have a lot of different
different relational database types
similarly we have non- relational you
must have heard about mongod one of the
most famous databases in the non-
relational domain and the difference
between these is while relational
databases force you to have a consistent
schema a very expected schema before you
can put data inside your database right
you have to have a predefined schema but
non- relational databases do not enforce
anything such as that right you can put
any kind of data and two entries of a
same table we don't use the term table
in the non-relational domain but
if you're doing a side by-side
comparison then a table is called a
collection in mongod right and inside a
collection each entry in relational it
is called rows and in non- relational or
M it is called a document in relational
domain each row will have the same kind
of data the structure of the rows will
always be the same right but in non-
relational domain each document can
follow different data structure okay
that's the primary advantage but
sometimes disadvantage when it comes to
the no SQL domain the advantage is
obviously it has a very flexible schema
so if you're doing some kind of
prototype you want to move fast you
don't want to spend time figuring out
your database schema enforcing the
schema maintaining it etc etc then you
can go with something like mongod and
move very fast without thinking about
your database schema you can you can
push data on the Fly you can fetch any
kind of data ET Etc right the
flexibility can be an advantage in some
scenarios so if you want to take an
example let's say we have a CRM CRM also
known as customer relationship
management software and inside this what
usually happens is it needs to maintain
accurate and consistent data about
customers data like contacts and all the
sales opportunity details etc etc right
and this data this critical data is more
suited to be inside a relational system
a relational database like postgress is
a very good choice because it provides
strong data integrity and allows for
complex queries and analyze
relationships between customers so a CRM
system is a very good candidate when you
are trying to decide between a
relational database and a non-
relational database in the same way if
we want to find a use case for a non-
relational database we can take an
example like CMS also known as content
management system so content Management
systems are used to push content from a
remote site to different different
content distribution system for example
let's say you have a blogging platform
so every time you want to add a new
article to your website you don't want
to open your code base and write a new
file and push it to GitHub and deploy it
Etc ET right you can pull that data in
your website dynamically from a Content
management system it can be something
like sanity Etc ET like we have a lot of
cmss in the market so you can pull that
data from a Content management system
and you can render that data so every
time you want to add a new article you
just have to log into your CMS system
and write that blog or article in the
markdown format and save it and the next
time someone refreshes your website the
new article will be fetched so when you
have a use case like this the content
that scms needs to store that is not
really structured so an article can have
an image it can have a code blog it can
have a YouTube embedding Etc ET like the
content can be of a lot of types so a
non- relational database something like
the mongod makes a lot of sense when you
don't know beforehand what are all the
different types of data that are going
to be stored here you just want to take
everything and dump it here right so in
these use cases mongod makes a lot of
sense but even though databases like
mongod they offer a lot of
flexibility they can also present
challenges in terms of data Integrity
which is a very important concept when
it comes to database systems and because
they often lack the strong constraints
and relationships of relational
databases is EAS easier to introduce
inconsistencies into the data since the
schema of the data the Integrity of the
data is not enforced at the database
level you have to do it at the
application Level which adds more
complexity to your code and of course it
is more error prone since application
code is generally changed a lot and it's
very easy to miss something right to
introduce new bugs to your code base so
now we have to make a choice right we
are going to learn about databases and
there are a lot of options in the market
we have relational we have non-
relational in inside relational we have
MySQL we have postgress we have site and
SQL Server a lot of different different
products and all of them pretty much
offer the same kind of features and all
of them can scale when it comes to
implementing in in your production
systems so we have to make a choice here
what database are we going to proceed
with and when you have a situation like
this going with postgress makes a lot of
sense why a couple of reasons one it is
open source and free right it is not a
proprietary software it is completely
open source you can go and look at the
source code of the postgress even though
you won't necessarily be doing that but
still it is an open- Source software and
a lot of companies prefer open source
softwares so that they can host it they
can deploy it in their own premises in
their own servers etc etc right second
the postgress dbms system it sticks to
the SQL standard so you can take any SQL
query and you can run it on a postra
system and it will perform the same way
it performs in a different database
system like MySQL or SQL Server because
the postgress database system sticks to
the SQL standard so in the future if you
want to migrate your database to a
different system then you won't have to
do a lot of work let's say you want to
migrate to myql for some reason right so
since postgress is SQL compli and you
have written all your migration
statements all your create update
statements and fet statements in
standard SQL format then you can just
change your database and do some minor
changes and you can easily switch from
postgress to myql right that's one of
the other reasons to go with postgress
it is very easy to migrate to a
different system if you need it three it
is very extensible which means it offers
a lot of features if you go to the
postgress documentation it is around,
1400 pages long and it offers a lot of
features pretty much covers every single
use case a typical SAS might encounter
right and it also has a very good
extension based system so you can
customize it depending on your own needs
fourth it is known for its reliability
and scalability and fifth I think this
is the one thing that makes it easy to
make the decision it has very good Json
support now as we discussed just before
this that one of the primary reasons to
go with something like mongod a non-
relational database is you can take any
kind of data so when we say any kind of
data we mostly mean Json any kind of
Json because in Json you can Prett much
store any kind of data right it can be
number it can be string other Json that
are embedded inside it arrays etc etc
right so you can store any kind of Json
as a document in a no SQL database in a
mongod database in the same way since
postgress offers a Json data type and it
has very good indexing and query
capabilities for Json Fields there is no
other reason to go for a different
database just for dynamic data right you
can use postgress with Json fields for
your needs of dynamic data as we saw in
the previous examples of a Content
management system if you have some kind
of content that you're getting from the
user and you want to save it in your
database and you don't have a strict
schema for that content you can go with
a typical Json schema and dump whatever
content that is coming from the user
there and you when you want to render it
you can fetch it from there and you
render it right there is no need to
switch to a non- relational database
just for the needs of your Dynamic data
right and because of all these features
postgress is pretty much the number one
choice when it comes to at least what I
have seen a lot of startups and a lot of
big companies also stick with postgress
and postgress is usually their first
choice and even though if you do your
own research you'll find a lot of
Articles where you'll see my SQL has a
lot of performance benefits etc etc
right but until you are serving millions
of users and you want to optimize a very
specific bottleneck of your application
you don't really need to think about
whether you should go with mycle or
whether you should go with posg right
since the rich set of features and the
very good Json support of postgress
postgress should be your first choice in
pretty much all your projects and that's
the reason in this video we are going to
go with postgress whatever all we are
going to learn about databases we will
learn in the context of hress and with
that I want to give a note here that
there are already thousands of free
resources available on YouTube elsewhere
like Udi you have paid resources and you
have hundreds of free resources that
cover the basics of SQL and postgressql
right SQL is when we say SQL it is the
language that you use to query and
postgress is the database system the
software on which we execute our SQL
queries right so there are a lot of
courses pre courses available right in
YouTube for both SQL and postgress right
so instead of repeating the same thing
instead of doing the all the create
table select the basics of Order byy
Group buy right all the basics of SQL
and the basics of postgress again in
this video we are going to save some
time and we are only going to stick with
some Concepts that are very relevant
when it comes to backend systems and we
are going to leave the basics so that
you can learn it elsewhere so if you
want you can pause this video right now
and just search in YouTube SQL Basics
you will get videos from 1 hour to 20
hours and same for postgress Basics so
you can choose a video according to your
own
Comfort what amount of comprehensiveness
that you need you can watch a video of 1
hour and come back to this video or you
can spend a couple of days learning
about SQL Basics and postgress Basics
and come back to this video right so
that is one of the prerequisite before
you proceed to the next section so we're
going to skip all the basics so that you
can do your own research this is table
plus it is a graphical software for
interacting with your databases and it
has a very modern UI fill
and this is the software that I use on
my day-to-day basis for all my database
query operations and exploring Etc ET
right so we'll be using this in this
entire video to go through different
different demos and to explore different
different concepts now starting with
what are all the different different
data types that we have available in
postgress I just want to bring this even
though just before this I mentioned that
we won't be covering the basics of
postgress and basics of SQL this video
but I feel this is an important piece of
information that we have to cover before
we proceed so that we don't have to
repeat this again when we are actually
talking about our backend system right
now we won't be going very deep into
each data type we'll just do a very high
level introduction this is a create
table query if you're already familiar
with the SQL language then you'll
recognize this this is how we create a
table in any relational database whether
it is POG gra myc etc etc right now we
are creating a table whose name is data
types demo and these are all the fields
which basically means these are all the
columns that are going to be in this
table for each row right so starting
with we have serial what does serial
mean it is just an integer data type but
each time we add a new entry into the
table this will increment the value so
by default let's say it starts with zero
right the next time you insert a row and
if you omit this ID field in your insert
statement value of this column for that
row is going to be one same way the next
time you enter something it'll be 2 3 4
right and usually we use serial or big
serial so there is another version which
basically has more capacity the
maximum number that you can store in big
serial is a lot higher when it comes to
serial so usually when you're dealing
with production systems we go with big
serial when we want to make ID as our
primary key so primary key is basically
a unique field using which we can
identify a particular row in a table
right now serial is an integer which is
going to be automatically incrementing
with each entry in our table then we
have small int we have big int and we
have integer all these three are
basically integers just that the
capacity as I said the maximum number
that you can store an integer so this is
how the scale works we have integer
Which is less than small end Which is
less than big end so depending on your
need you can either go with integer
small end or big end same way we have
decimal and numeric which are mostly
considered identical you can use either
of them they pretty much much behave the
same way right and the purpose of this
is what does this 10 and this two means
is it basically says you can store a
number you can store a number in this
format right on the right side of the
decimal point there will always be two
numbers right that's what this two means
on the right side of the decimal point
there will always be two numbers and
what do 10 means is across all these
numbers in this complete number across
all these numbers in this numerical
repes representation the maximum amount
you can store is 10 so you can store
something like 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 dot 9 0
right now if you count it we have 10
numbers we cannot store something like
three here we cannot add something like
this because the maximum we can store is
10 numbers across this whole numerical
representation right and on the right
side we have two numbers this is what
this means and the question mostly
people ask is what is the difference
between decimal or numeric something
like this as compared to something like
real or double Precision or float right
now the difference is a little
complicated floating Point numbers they
can be real double float whatever you
call them they are represented in a very
different manner as compared to the
decimal counterparts which we have in
decimal and numeric so the thumb rule
that you should have is if accuracy is
an important aspect for that field so
let's say you are storing an information
like price for a field like price
accuracy is very important right because
it is going to be involved in a lot of
calculation
and a lot of things can go wrong if you
have different different representations
of the same number in different
different systems etc etc right the
accuracy is very important when it comes
to a field like price so in this case
you should always go with decimal right
you should always stick with either
decimal or numeric but standard says you
can go with decimal right so if accuracy
is an important aspect then always go
with decimal because floating Point
representation
can have different different values
across different different systems
because of the way they are stored
because of the way they are processed
they have a very different algorithm
when it comes to rendering or at the
same time let's say you have a field
like size right and it is a size of a
area it can be something like five
67.
8987 something like this right some
fractional number some floating Point
number where accuracy let's say if 89
87 turns into 9 or 8 9 67 something like
this very small discrepancies in the
accuracy or the representation of the
number does not impact a lot of
difference in your systems when you have
numbers like this you should go with
floating points right now if you have a
question like if decimals are always
accurate then why shouldn't we always go
with decimals and the reason is because
decimals always have accurate
representation of their value and
because floating points don't have that
kind of accuracy floating points are
considered faster when it comes to
storage when it comes to performing
different different calculations etc etc
right floating points are very fast that
is the reason in a lot of scientific
computation based domains roting points
are preferred as compared to decimals or
decimal
representations so you should always
evaluate what kind of value that you're
going to store and if it is not
something that is going to have a lot of
impact if there are small discrepancies
in the representation of the number then
you should go with float because they
are very fast to process and very
preferable in these kinds of scenarios
but if it is a value like price or
something something very critical where
accuracy matters a lot then always go
with decimals right that covers pretty
much all the floating Point data types
then we have a very interesting category
which are string categories and we have
three types in that we have care V care
and text now all these three data types
store text that is the similarity
between the three data types the
difference is when we say car 10 and
inside this field if he says store
something like AB if you store something
like this inside a data type which is
declared as this and the length is
defined as 10 then what the database
system will do is it will pad extra
eight spaces in that field before saving
because we have defined the length is 10
and it is a care data type right that is
the property of character data type
whatever length that you have defined
does not matter the actual value that
you're are trying to insert it will
always try to store the same length if
you don't provide the same length then
it will just pad some empty spaces right
inside whatever way it is represented it
will add some empty spaces and it that's
how it will store it and that is the
reason people came up with another
standard which is called Vare also known
as variable character now the way it
works is when we say the length is 255
what it means 255 is the maximum length
that you can store in this field but if
you store something like this AB then
the length will be two right it won't
add Extra Spaces just to make a for this
255 length if you store a smaller value
then it will be two if you store
something like a b c d then it'll be
four etc etc right depending depending
on what Valu are actually being inserted
into the database it will adjust itself
just that the maximum amount the maximum
number that you can store is 255 you
cannot exceed that if you do then you
will get a database level error now the
last thing is text which is a very
modern alternative to Ware so imagine
Vare without any length field basically
any amount of text
a text of any length that's what text
means you don't enforce any length on
this field you can store a text of any
length usually it has some kind of upper
limit like 250 MB or something something
you can do your own research for that
but yeah and when we say 250 MB of text
it is very very very long text right
usually we won't be needing that much
but that's what it means now the
question is when you want to store a
string which one you should go with the
first thing is never choose care right
it it is a very old standard people used
to do it way back so either go with
varer or text you can use care if you
know beforehand that the length is
always going to be the same right it
cannot be variable so let's say you are
storing the codes of all the days of a
week so the values can be M Mo or Tu or
W Etc you get my point right if you have
a requirement where you know that you
have all these values and all of them
have the same length then you can go
with a data type like Car 2 and this way
you won't be wasting a lot of space
because of the variable length of
different different entries of the data
right only go with care if you have a
use case like is but if it is a general
text let's say name of a customer name
of a product etc etc or a description
Etc ET then either go with Vare or text
now how do you choose Vare versus text
what I believe personally is you should
always go with text because if you go
explore the documentation of Whois they
themselves recommend that always use
text which is the model alternative of
Vare without length because most people
what they confus with is if you use Vare
with 255 this is going to perform better
as compared to a field like text or you
cannot index a field uh we'll cover
index shortly but people believe you
cannot index a field of type text there
are a lot of misconceptions around this
because other databases databases like
MySQL SQL Server sqlite they have
different different conventions the way
they operate the way they function are
very different from postgress and when
people switch between different
different databases they get confused or
they are misguided so if you explore the
official documentation of postgress they
recommend that always go with text there
is pretty much no performance difference
between Vare or text and the second
thing which is my personal opinion that
using something like Vare 250
which is by the way a convention from
myql that people from myql which was a
very popular database and that has a
Convention of using Vare 255 and that's
the reason a lot of people still use
this and
255 is at least when it comes to
postgress 255 has a meaning in the
context of a mySQL database but when it
comes to postgress people just use the
number 255 as a random number right it
has no meaning whatsoever in a postgress
database and people just use it without
thinking just because the way it has
always been done and that's why I
personally believe instead of going with
a random number like 255 go with text
and and the reason is let's say later on
you want to increase the length for some
use case let's say you are dealing with
a field called description and you just
set the length is 255 as V so later on
you want to increase the length so to
cater to that requirement you have to do
a database level migration which affects
a lot of data and a lot riskier of
course migrations are performed on a
day-to-day basis but still you should
always avoid a database level migration
if you can right and that's the reason
using something like text and enforcing
the length for whatever it is on your
application Level and since we are not
in the data engineering domain we are
not in the data analyst domain people in
those domains they usually deal with SQL
directly right they have some kind of
interface and they write SQL directly
and they see the result of the SQL data
directly etc etc right SQL is their
first point of interaction but as
backend Engineers when we are dealing
with backend systems we usually interact
with SQL databases
through a driver right we have different
different drivers depending on what
programming language that we are talking
about and that's how we interact with
the database through a driver and we
have a lot of application code when we
are dealing with the data that's the
reason we can enforce the length or
whatever constraint it is on the
application code so that our database
migrations all the database system
database statements are simpler to read
and simpler to maintain so let's say
someone new someone new comes over and
they look at this they see vat 255 and
they think that this has some meaning
even though the person who just created
it they just added it without thinking
right it is just a random number for
them but if someone new comes over they
will think there is some meaning to this
number or there is some meaning to this
10 number they will try to understand
and where this is coming from and since
there is no documentation they'll try to
dig through the code Etc ET there's a
lot of headache that comes with it
because a number a number like this a
number like this this represents that it
has some kind of meaning even though it
doesn't most of the times right so
instead of this if you go with just text
then it is a lot simpler to read a lot
simpler to write these migration
statements all the SQ statements because
you won't have to think about these lens
and all and if someone new comes over
and they read it they just think that it
is a text field it is a character field
right there is no extra meaning to this
so those are some of the concepts
surrounding string Fields string data
types in post moving on we have Boolean
we can store true or false in this field
we have date we can just store the date
in this and we have time where we can
store the time right in hour minute
seconds format then we have time stamp
for storing the information of date and
time at the same time then we have time
stamps with is extra Zed at the end
which just means store the time zone
information also in this so it will
store time stamp and a time zone
information then we have interval for
storing like 10 days or one week etc etc
right those kinds of datas then we have
uu ID U ID is a very a popular choice
when it comes to making table primary
keys right because of their Ur flend and
their unique nature so that's the reason
posg offers a native uid type right
inside the database then we have Json
and Json b as I have mentioned before
postgress offers native Json and we have
an extra type which is called Json B
also known as Json binary and the
primary difference between Json and Json
B is when we use a field called Json
this will be stored as a plain text a
plain text with the key value format
that we usually see when we are reading
Json but when we use this Json B this
will be converted into a different
format postgress will serialize it into
its own native Json format for
efficiency purpose so that it can
perform better it can perform a lot of
query capabilities etc etc right there
something that is limited to postgress
it is not an SQL standard and most of
the times you should go with Json B
because of the performance advantage
that it offers then we have the aray
types you can store an arrow of
different different data types right
store an arrow of integer you can store
an AR of Json date time Etc whatever all
the different different data types that
we have then we have some other random
data types like storing Network
addresses Mac addresses and geometrical
points XML etc etc that we don't really
use on our data basis but if you do want
to use it you can explore the official
documentation and you'll find more
information on that and this is how we
insert data into our database we write
insert into the table name and the Order
of the all the fields that we want to
insert the data in and then we provide
all the values in the same order that we
wrote Our fields in right and this is
how we are inserting all the data this
is an example example small integer this
is an integer big integer as you can see
it is a lot higher than a normal integer
then we have decimal we have real double
Precision which basically floating Point
representations then we have character
Vare and text and we have bullan we can
either pass true or false here we have
date we have time and hour minute
seconds format we have time stamp where
we have the date and the time we have
time stamps you have date time and the
time zone information then we have
interval have uid this this is what a
typical uid looks like we have Json Json
B and while inserting even though Json
and Json B looks the same but postgress
serializes Json B into a different
format for faster processing and faster
retrial right then we have array then we
have IP addresses Mac addresses
geometrical points and XML etc etc right
all the data types that we basically saw
and that's pretty much all about about
all the data types that we are going to
deal with as backend engineers in a
typical database system next up what we
are going to do is we are going to
design the database of a project
management platform in the previous
video we created the apis we designed we
modeled the apis of a project management
platform similarly to understand
different concepts of databases and and
different relevant Concepts not just
theoretical concepts are very Advanced
concept that we don't necessarily use on
a day-to-day basis but very relevant
Concepts in database systems especially
in postgress we are going to design a
database of a project management
platform and we are also going to write
queries for different different apis
using the same databases now before we
get into that just want to bring up one
topic which are known as migrations in
systems especially in production systems
you don't necessarily just open a
software like table plus and you just
start writing queries right you cannot
do that because if something goes wrong
or even if something does not go wrong
but there is no way to track what all
changes that are applied to a particular
databas over time or who applied it
right there is no way to control the
version or the control the state of the
databases across different different
times right and that is the reason most
database systems follow something called
as database migrations now database
migrations are basically different
different files let's say we have 1. SQL
we have a folder which are called
migrations inside the folder database
right you have a folder structure like
this you have DB folder inside that you
have migrations and inside that you have
different different files you have 1
dsql you have 2. SQL you have 3 dsql etc
etc right and in each file you have a
couple of SQL statements normal SQL
statements nothing fancy right you have
create table or create index or drop
table etc etc and with that you have a
tool usually it's a command line tool we
have a lot of command line tools for
performing migrations and maintaining
migrations for example Le we have dbate
or we have go migrate right a lot of
this famous tools now what this tool
does it goes to this location DB
migrations and goes through all these
files in this sequential Manner and
because of that we write the names of
these files in a sequential manner
either we perform some kind of numerical
series 1 2 3 or we add dates uh
timestamps and since time stamps follow
a single uh flow that's the reason we
get sequential files right okay now what
this tool does it goes through all those
files in that sequence and applies all
the SQL statements basically executes
all these SQL queries on that particular
databases whatever database that you
have configured in your environment it
executes all this SQL statements on that
data database inside migration also we
have two kinds of migration we have up
migrations and we have down migrations
now some of the modern approaches of
handling databases they don't really
believe or they don't really Implement
down migrations but this is the standard
way of operating right you have up
migrations up migrations are basically
whatever change that you want to do you
want to create a new table so you write
create table etc etc you want to create
a new type let's say you want to create
a new enum type you write create type
enom etc etc then you want to create
some indexes whatever all the create
statements you write one by one right
with proper SQL syntax or postgress
syntax then depending on the tool let's
say a tool like dbate what it does it
divides the same file the same SQL file
let's say 1. SQL into two sections one
section with a comment for up migrations
and another section for down migrations
now the purpose of down migration is
whatever change you did in your up
migrations whatever change you applied
to the database in the down migration
you have to revert all those changes so
that the reason for having this feature
called down migration is let's say you
applied some migrations you applied some
changes to your database systems and
something goes wrong right or something
breaks in your production system or
anything can go wrong what what you want
to do you want to roll back to previous
version of the database without any
changes right the state has to be the
same for that to happen you have to have
down migrations so that all the changes
that you did in your up migration the
down migrations can rever that so that
you can go to a previous state you can
roll back okay that's how a migration
workflow works you have a tool and that
tool usually creates a table called SK
scha something like that in your
database and using which it tracks that
which is the current version of the
database right let's say you have 1 SQL
2. SQL 3. SQL right then in your schema
table you will have something like four
right current schema is four because
four is the latest changes that you have
applied on your database when you come
back and you want to add another file.
5. SQL before you apply that file before
you up that migration your current data
schema will still have four right that's
how the tool works you have a migration
tool which goes through all your SQL
files applies all the SQL queries on
your databases one by one if it is an up
migration then it applies all the
changes if it is a down migration it
reverse all the changes for that version
now the question is why do we need
migrations there are a couple of reasons
one reason as I've already mentioned you
cannot just open a graphical tool and
execute SQL statements because that's
very hard to keep track of what are the
all the changes that you made right
unless you want to save it to a
particular file and you want to commit
to git etc etc and after all those
things you will come up with your own
migration system that's why we have this
concept called migrations couple of
advantages of using migration is one as
I said keeping track of
database changes keeping track of
database changes over time right you
have a file you have a lot of files in a
particular folder which is committed to
your version control system let's say
it's git or git lab bit bucket whatever
platform that you follow to Version
Control your code usually your migration
statements stay with your code and you
commit it to get GitHub whatever
platform you follow and over the time
you keep adding new migration files to
the same folder and that's how you keep
track of all the changes that are
happening to your database schema second
is roll back as I already mentioned if
something goes wrong you can roll back
to a particular version so that's pretty
much all there is to it migrations are a
system using which you apply new changes
on top of your databases you can add new
tables you can modify tables you can
create indexes you can create triggers
etc etc right whatever change that you
want to perform on a database you have
to create a new migration for it because
relational databases follow a particular
strict schema you cannot just insert
data randomly into the databases you
have to follow a particular schema
that's the reason we have this migration
statements to make changes to the
database over time using any command
line tool now we will start modeling our
database for our project management
platform and for that we'll write
migrations okay here I have my vs code
open this is where we'll write all our
SQL statements to model our database
right so for the sake of migration we
are going to use d mate it's a command
line migration tool that helps applying
all the changes to your database right
and for that we have to provide the URL
of our database to the tool and for that
we have to create a new environment
file. EnV and inside that we can create
a variable called database URL and the
tool will pick up the value of our
postgress database URL from this
location okay so to create our first
migration dbate offers a command you can
write dbate new create users St that
sounds right so press enter it creates a
new folder called DB inside that another
folder called migrations and inside that
a migration file so as I said it can
follow a sequential number like 1 2 3 4
5 or time stamps whichever sequence that
you want to prefer right in this case
it's adding a time stamp then the name
of our file which is created users table
for now it's empty we'll add our
migration statements here pretty soon so
this is how as I mentioned this section
is for writing out down migrations
whatever SQL statements that we write
after this comment are considered as
down migrations and whatever SQL
statements that we write before this
down migration and after this up
migration are considered as our up
migrations right now to save some time
I'll just paste all the SQL statements
and then we can go through that one by
one right I've pasted all the SQL
queries that are needed to perform this
migration the up migrations and create
all the necessary tables so let's
explore all the statements one by one to
understand all the concepts surrounding
it the first thing that you notice is we
are
creating some data types called as enums
right now enums are basically all those
values for which you have a predefined
set of allowed values for example we
have a field called status in the
projects table and for that we only want
to allow these three values the project
status can either be active or completed
or achieved active or completed or
archived right in the same way for tasks
in the task table the task status either
can be pending in progress completed or
cancelled same way for members they
either can have the role owner admin or
member the reason for using a data type
called enum instead of just going with
our standard text because first thing
data Integrity data Integrity when we
say in the context of databases we mean
we leave the responsibility of checking
the validity the checking the accuracy
of the data
to the database instead of our
application code because we created
types these enum types and we used these
types let's say we created this type
called project status and as you can see
we used it here right in the status
field that's the type of the status
field is our custom inom type which is
project status because we did this
whenever we insert data or whenever we
are trying to update data in the
projects table and and in the field of
status if we try to insert any random
string or let's say we try to install we
have active completed or archived we try
to inster something something if we try
to insert some random string like this
we will get a database level error we
don't have to check this in our
application code we can leave that
responsibility for the database we can
check it in our application code that is
just decreasing the scope of the error
but still to make it more robust to make
it more secure we can provide a set of
allowed values and we can use that
custom type for any field then whenever
we insert some data whenever we update
some data the database will check
whether that data whatever value that we
are providing for the Project's status
whether it is one of these if it's not
then we'll get a database level error
okay the first thing is data Integrity
the second thing is documentation and I
think this part the second point is more
important than the first point because
the first point data Integrity this we
can do in our application code right we
since we are talking in the context of
backends we have a programming language
in our hand and we can validate whether
whatever status that is coming from the
user that is coming from the front end
or whatever application code whether it
is one of these strings or not completed
or archived we can do that in our
application code but another advantage
of using enums in our migration
statements is when you're going through
your old migration statements for
debugging something or let's say you are
unboarding a new team member into your
team and they are going through the
database migration statements to
understand what all changes that the
project went through over the last
couple of months or the last couple of
years and they want to understand right
what is the state of the database what
are the past states of the database what
changes happened over the time etc etc
right and when they are doing that when
they are going through all the database
migration statements if they come across
this table called projects and they see
the field status and if it is of type
text but in our application code we are
only doing active completed archived now
there is no way for them to find out
this piece of information that you
cannot put any arbitrary text into your
status field it has to be either of
these three right so to find out that
piece of information they have to go
through all the application code they
have to see what what are all the places
where this field is used and to track
down all those use cases then they can
boil it down to these three values which
is a lot of headache right so using enum
type provides some kind of documentation
for you for your team members for your
future team members so that at one
glance you can tell what are all the
allowed fields that can be in a
particular field which makes everything
very easy to understand right so that's
all about enum fields we are creating
three enum types and this is a syntax we
write create type the name of the enum
and we write as enum and inside the
braces we provide all the allowed values
we create three types three enum types
and we are going to use this in our
future tables now moving on we are
creating a users table since it's a
project management platform of course
we'll have users right so that's the
first table we are starting with we are
creating a table called users and if you
notice this each table has some default
fields we have ID we have created it we
have updated it same for user profiles
you have ID created at updated at for
projects we have ID created at updated
so each table has this kind of metadata
kind of field the ID is not really a
metadata it is the primary key and by
primary key I mean using this ID we can
uniquely identify a particular Row in
this table right let's say we want to
find out or let's say in our backend API
we have a requirement that we want the
information of user okay since it's a uu
ID let's generate a random uu ID and
let's paste it and a comment here here
okay now we have a requirement in our
back end we have a API which takes the
user ID in a dynamic parameter and we
have to return the details of that user
so this is the ID of that user and we
have to find out the information of the
user using this ID now if we don't make
a particular field let's say the ID
field primary key okay we don't assign
the
condition primary key to a particular
field there's a couple of things that
can happen this primary key property has
some implicit properties those
properties are if you write primary key
for a particular field that field cannot
be null not null and it also has a
unique constraint so relational
databases have this concept called
constraints right you can apply a
particular condition particular property
to a field
and that property or that condition will
protect that field from going corrupt
okay that's a very high level definition
we'll see what that means when we
encounter more examples so when we say
primary key it means it implicitly has
these two properties not null and unique
though so this field cannot be null and
this will always be unique if there is
another entry with the same value gets
inserted into this table we'll get a
database level errors and because of
this implicit properties and some other
foreign key Behavior we use this
property called primary key for our ID
field so each table will have a field by
convention called ID and we will assign
the property primary Q to that which
will help us fetch different different
information of the user okay now what we
are saying we have a field called ID it
is of type uu ID and it will be a
primary key for this table and by
default if the ID is not provided when
an insert statement is executed by
default generate a random U ID okay this
is what this means this is by default
natively provided by postgress so if we
don't provide the ID field which we
generally don't we leave it to postgress
the database system to generate a random
ID for us and to assign it to that R
next we have another field called email
and it is of type text it is not null
one thing to keep in mind is by default
all the fields in a postgress table can
have null values unless you explicitly
specify that it cannot have null values
More than 70% of your tables Fields
should have the not null constraint
right because this not null constraint
enables the database to have a
consistent state if you don't add this
then the application can push null
values into the table even though you
don't do it uh intentionally because a
lot of database interactions are also
dealt with automated scripts so that
script can have a bug and you'll end up
with a lot of null values in your
database which makes things very very
difficult right so for a lot of reasons
like that always try to stick to n Nal
okay unless you have a reason for that
field to be null okay that's the reason
we are writing not null here we have a
field called email it is of type text
and it cannot be null and we have
constraint called unique but this means
is each door of this table will have a
unique email the moment you try to push
another row with the same email address
that already exists in the table we will
get a database level error that it
violates the unique constraint okay and
since email is something that we don't
want to create two users with the same
email we are applying this constraint
called unique next we have a field
called full name it is of type text
again not null then we have password
hash it is again of type text and not
null since we don't directly store the
plain text value of the password we hash
the password and store it this it's
called password hash just a name then we
have two other fields create at and
update at and the reason is we want want
to know when this user was created okay
when was the first time this user was
created in our database that's the
reason we maintain this field called
created it and usually we don't manually
insert it we are providing this default
property and we are saying if created is
not passed by default you can take the
current time stamp and you can put it in
that row okay and it is of type
timestamp with time zone okay this is of
type time stamp with time zone this will
have the date the time and the time zone
information same way updated it we
create this field so that we can keep
track of when was the last time we
updated some field of this row okay and
that can have some use cases for example
if you have a table in your front end
and you want to display all the users in
the order of when was the last time
their name was updated something like
this right so in that case you can use
this updated it property to sort by and
that's all about users table some of the
other things to notice here is all our
tables have this plural form right we
have users we have user profiles
projects and that is a standard a lot of
people also prefer the singular form
user user profile project Etc ET it's a
matter of what your team has decided and
what your company has decided but the
industry standard is to mostly stick
with the plural form second thing all
the table names and all the field names
will be small case and snake case and by
that I mean if it is a single word it
will have small case of course as we
have users ID email right all small case
if it has multiple words let's say full
name password hash created it update
then we'll use snake case if you are
coming from other progr programming
languages or Etc you might have the
instinct to go with uh camel case right
you might want to write something like
full name with n capital and you want to
merge and get rid of the snake case but
that is not a good idea because in
postgress everything is case insensitive
by Nature so even if you write camel
case postgress will take it as so if you
write something like this will name
pogress will understand this will name
unless you write it like this full name
with quotes and when you're writing your
application code using double Cod again
and again can be very difficult and make
the code very ugly that's the reason we
always try to stick with small case we
make everything small case and if you
have multiple wordss we stick with snake
case so that we can avoid using double
codes to make postgress understand case
sensitivity okay that's some of the
things that you have to remember moving
on
we have another table called user
profiles now if you check the commment
it says one to one relationship with
users now you might have a question like
why are we creating a different table
for storing information of the user
right why don't we store all this
information in the same table and the
reason for that is you when you're
designing a database you have to take
into account some of the different
different situations that you might
modify your data in so if you think
about a user the only times you are
going to make changes to a users entry
in the users table is when they are
modifying their profile and their
profile can have lot of other
information for the sake of this example
we have just limited it to their image
URL their bio their phone number but
user can have other fields also right
they can have their social media
accounts and they can have their
websites and their projects etc etc a
lot of different information a user
profile can have and because of that we
in the future we have to make a lot of
migrations to the user table itself and
we have to constantly modify the users
row again and again and we don't
necessarily have to do that if we
abstract out the users profile
information into a different table which
can scale over time which can get bigger
over time and which does not affect the
primary users table directly these are
some of the bu cases that we go with one
to one relationship for storing users
profile information for storing user
preference for storing metadata etc etc
right this is a common convention that
you will see when it comes to modeling
your database so we have a table called
user profiles inside this we'll store
the information of the user for this
what we can do is we don't necessarily
have to create another ID field because
there is a one to one relationship with
another table each entry of that table
or each row of that table will only have
one row in this table that's why it's
called one to one relationship and
because of that we can get rid of this
ID and we can make the user ID which is
the foreign key in this table as the
primary key so we can write uu ID then
instead of not null we can write primary
key and we can also get rid of this
unique thing now this user ID field is
both the primary key and the foreign key
in this table and we have some other
fields for storing the image URL the bio
the phone number and if you notice we
are not writing notal here because these
can be optional Fields a user can choose
not to have a bio they can choose not to
provide the phone number or to have a
image customized image etc etc right
that's the reason we are not writing not
n in these fields okay moving on we then
have another table called projects now
the same thing happens here we have a
primary key with ID and we are
generating a default random ID each time
we enter a new project into the database
same way we have the name of the project
which is not null and we have the
description of the project which can be
null we don't care much of the
description but we have to have the name
of the project that's why we are writing
not null here same way we have a status
field which is using our custom enum
type is project status is not null and
if you don't provide any value for this
field by default it will be in the
active State okay usually when we are
going with enum types we provide a
default value with one entries of that
enum to make easier for us so that we
don't have to explicitly push that value
from our application code then we have
an owner ID which is a foreign key and
we write it like this it is a not n
level field and says it references the
users table and this is a constraint
that on delete restrict and this is what
it means this owner ID is the foreign
key for stable and it references the
user table and usually this is how we
write users ID and because the ID field
is the primary key in the users table we
can omit this part and we can only say
references users like we are doing here
and it means owner ID references the ID
field in the user table users table okay
now the second part we are putting a
condition here saying that on delete
restrict this is also known as refer
differential Integrity which basically
means that we can protect the data
across different tables using the
relationship between those tables in
this case what we are saying if someone
deletes this particular user which user
the user whose ID is in this table the
project table as the owner ID so let's
say we have a users table and we have
projects table in ID field we have
for the sake of this example let's say
we have ID is one and in projects field
we have another entry owner ID in this
row owner ID is one so this user has
created a project that's why in the
projects table we have a row which has a
field called owner ID and the value is
one when we write on delete restrict
what it means is if someone tries to
delete this user this user whose ID is
one the database system will check
whether this user has some corresponding
rows in projects field since it has what
it will do is it will check what is the
referential Integrity constraint what is
the condition we are mentioning here
since we are saying restrict it will
fail that operation you cannot delete a
user unless you delete the project first
that's what it means using referential
Integrity we can put some restrictions
on some operations on some tables using
the relationship between those tables
and inside referential Integrity we have
couple of constants one is on delete
restrict second is on delete Cascade and
what on delate Cascade means let's say
if we had instead of on delate restrict
we had on delate Cascade so when someone
deletes a particular user the database
system will check if there are entries
in the projects table which has owner ID
as one it will also delete those
projects instead of restricting it will
Cascade which means it will delete the
user and all the associated projects
from the projects table they also have
another con condition called set null
and set default which basically means if
someone deletes a particular user then
owner ID in case of set null will be set
null but since we are saying not null
here and if you try to set null then
we'll get a database level error and
this operation will not go through same
way set default will try to set the
default value if some default value is
provided while creating the table these
are pretty much all the referential
Integrity constraints that we use on a
day-to-day basis to protect our data
from going corrupt to protect our data
from going inaccurate right so this
basically means we cannot delete a user
as long as they have some Associated
projects in the project table because of
this statement on delete restrict and
owner ID is a foreign key and similarly
we have created it and updated it moving
on we have tasks which another table and
in the same way we have a primary key
called ID and we have a foreign key here
called project ID it is a type uu ID
because the primary key of projects is
ID and ID is of Type U ID and since
we'll be storing the values of ID here
this is is also U ID and we are saying
not n which means there cannot exist a
task without an Associated project ID
that cannot be an orphan task that's
what we are saying here it cannot be
null then we have the foreign key
constraint the referential Integrity
thing you're saying it references
projects and since we have AED the field
it will check which is the primary key
in Project table since ID is the primary
key ID is the forign key here then we
have the referential integrity
constraint we are saying on delete
Cascade now as I've already mentioned on
delete Cascade means if we have a
project with ID one and if we have a
task with id2 and project ID 1 this is a
projects row there is a task row and if
we delete the projects row with ID one
it will check that project one has
Associated tasks in the task table so
what it will do is since we are redit in
on delete Cascade it will delete all the
tasks which are associated with the
project ID one because of referential
Integrity this is a very useful Concept
in relational databases then moving on
we have the title field is of type text
and not null and description which can
be null and of type text then we have
the priority which is an
integer we can only store 1 2 3 4 etc
etc and it cannot be null by default if
we the application does not pass any
values we are setting the value one then
in the end we have a constraint of check
in po or any relational systems we have
different different constraints one we
have already seen is unique so for that
field in the whole table you can have
only one value for a particular field
and that value will be unique across the
whole table then we have not null which
enforces the condition that you cannot
set null in this field similarly we have
another constraint these are called
constraints or conditions that we are
putting on a particular field similarly
we have check constant which basically
using which we can put a particular
condition on a field a custom condition
and the operation the transaction will
only go through as long as this
condition is true that's what check
means so if we see here you're saying
when we are trying to insert the
priority field if you do not pass
anything set the default as one but if
you do pass anything we are checking
that the value should be either 1 to
five that is the condition that we are
putting here the value of priority
should be 1 to 5 so that no one can
insert some random value like 55 into
the priority field we're only
considering from value 1 to five moving
on we have a field called status and
this is a custom enum type and which we
created at the start is of task status
and it can have pending in progress
completed cancelled so the status will
have our custom type task status it
cannot be null and by default the
application if does not pass anything we
are setting the value of pending here
then we have a due date which is of type
date we not considering time here or
time zone we're just considering date
here then we have assigned to we again
have a foreign key condition so assign
to is a foreign key which references
users ID from the users table and the
constraint the referential Integrity
constraint that we are putting here is
if the user of that ID is deleted and
that users's ID is present in the
assigned to field in the task table then
for that row we are setting the value of
assigned to as null that's what this
means and similarly we have created it
and updated it the nice thing about the
foreign key constraint is because you
have written that assigned to or in this
case owner ID right since these are
foreign keys and by default relational
databases have this constraint called
foreign key constraint because of that
you cannot enter anything into the
assigned to field if you try to enter
some random string or some random uu ID
it can be a valid uu ID but that U ID
has to be present in the users table as
a valid ID if that is not present then
your insertion will fail okay that's
what we mean by Foreign key constraint
if you write references users this make
sure that this U ID whatever uid that
you are passing for this field this has
a corresponding user entry in the users
field another thing to notice here is
this pattern is called one to many
because we are writing project ID here
which is a foreign key which references
the ID field in the proess table which
basically means that if we have a
project with id1 that can have multiple
tasks right multiple tasks in the task
table which refers to this project using
the field project ID in the task table
right it can it will be one here and
same way it will be one here it will be
one here it will be one here right one
project can have multiple tasks in the
task table that's why it's called one to
many relationship and this is how we
implement it
the first kind of relationship which is
one to one relationship the way we
Implement that is we take the primary
key of the main table and we create
another table and we make the primary
key of the main table as the primary key
of the second table also but instead of
writing just ID we write the name of the
table with ID so because we had the
table called users for a one toone
relationship with the user profiles
table what we did we wrote ID and we
used the users primary key from this
table as a primary key in this table and
instead of just writing ID we wrote it
as user ID is the primary key in this
table this is how we implemented one to
one relationship and the way we
Implement one to many relationship is we
take the ID field and we create another
table but we don't make that as a
primary key we keep that as a foreign
key only and we refer to that using the
ID primary key right that's how we
Implement one to many relationship in
the next one we'll see how we Implement
many to many relationship so moving on
this is the last table it's called
project members the reason we are
creating this table is we want to keep
track of what are all the projects that
a user is part of at the same time we
also want to keep keep track of what are
all the users that are associated with
the project so you can look at it both
ways and when you have a condition like
that when you have a condition when you
take the same thing and you can look at
it both ways and it makes sense that's
how we know that it is a many to many
relationship because if we have a user
that user can be part of multiple
projects at the same time right you can
be part of multiple projects at the same
time same way if we have a project that
project can have multiple users at the
same time right a project can not be
limited to a single user same way user
cannot be limited to a single project
that's why projects and users have many
to many relationship and we want to keep
track of that relationship by creating a
different table and usually we call this
table as linking table and we implement
this pattern when we are implementing
many to many relationship okay by
creating a different table for the sake
of maintaining the relationship with
between two tables that's why it's
called a linking table and this is how
we do it okay we have to make some
changes to that instead of creating an
ID here what we'll do we'll remove this
we'll remove this row we'll take foreign
keys from both the tables so what we'll
do is we have project ID here and we
have user ID here project ID is a
reference to the ID field in the project
table and we are seeing on delete
Cascade as the referential integrity
constraint same way user ID is a foreign
key which references the users table and
the referential Integrity constraint is
the same thing on delete casket which
basically means if the project is
deleted delete all the entries in the
project members table same way if the
user is deleted delete on the ENT in the
project members table okay and in the
end what we'll do instead of writing
unique we'll write primary key primary
key and what this means is this is a
composite primary key in the Technic
terms so it is a combination of two
fields which are foreign Keys
referencing primary keys of two other
tables and we take those two and we
create the primary key so if a user is
part of a project then that will have
one entry in projects members table
let's say you have users table and you
have projects table okay and you have
users 1 2 3 and projects 1 2 2 three and
we want to maintain the relationship
that let's say through some user Journey
user one was added to project and we
want to maintain this relationship in
our projects members table what we can
do we take project ID since it's a many
to many relationship what we do we take
the project ID which is two okay this is
the project ID and you take the user ID
which is one right take the user ID is
one and this combined will have one
entry in the project members
relationship because user one being part
of project two is a single event right
that cannot be duplicated user one
cannot be part of project two multiple
times same way project 2 cannot have
user one multiple times okay that's the
reason what we did we took this
combination project two and user one we
took this we said that these two
combined will be the primary key for
this table because primary key
implicitly enforces some constraints
constraints like unique and not null so
what we are saying this combination can
only have one entry in this table which
will be a unique entry and that cannot
be null and because it is a primary key
using this combination we can uniquely
identify this Row in this table okay
this is the CR of how we Implement many
to many relationship in postgress or any
relational database using a linking
table which will have a composite
primary key of the two tables that we
are trying to link the rest of the
things remain same we have created it
and updated that and we have a role
field which is again a custom enum so we
are saying it is a member role which we
have created if we go to the top you're
saying member role it can be either
owner admin or member Okay so
if a user is part of a project in that
project whatever characteristics that
user will have or whatever project
characteristics for that user it will
have all those informations we can store
in the project member St and because
role is specific to the situation where
a user is part of a project that's why
we have we have kept the information of
role in this table okay and by default
we are setting the role member and that
that's pretty much all our up migrations
same way as I mentioned we have to
mention our down migrations all the
changes that we did we created a couple
of types we created a couple of tables
now in the down migrations what you have
to do we have to revert that so that
when we want to roll down to a
particular version using these
statements our database can do the roll
back okay we have to explicitly say that
these are the down migrations that the
database tool the migration tool can use
to roll back to a previous version okay
and we are simply dropping all the
tables and after dropping all the tables
we are dropping all the types in the
reverse order that we created them
that's pretty much all the tables okay
so let's go ahead and apply these
migrations to our database so that we
can see if it works or not and to apply
it dbat has a command you can write DB M
and you can write up okay and here
applying this migration file and it says
applied in this
milliseconds and then we go here if we
do a refresh and you can see you expand
it a little bit these are all the tables
that we just created you can go here and
you can check the schema it has project
ID user ID role C project all the
schemas right since we have not inserted
any databases yet all these entries are
empty all these tables are empty and you
can also see there is a special table
called schema migrations and this one is
created by dbit as I've already
mentioned all these migrations tools
they have to keep track of what is the
current state of the database so that
they can decide what migrations to apply
right so after this after our first
migration if you create a different file
the database tool will check what is the
current version and it will start
applying the migrations from that point
on instead of duplicating the Mig s and
because if it tries to execute the same
statements again it will get an error
from postgress that this table already
exists you cannot run the same
statements again that's the reason the
migration tool maintains a table call
schema migration and in that it has a
single field called version and it keeps
tag of what is the current version of
the migration that we have now that we
have our tables ready we want to insert
some data into it now in production
environments when you actually deploy
this back end you will have normal user
flows right people will come to your
platform they'll use the front end to
sign up with forms and they'll create
projects with different different forms
you have this pre defined flows when the
data will come into your database but
when you're creating your backend when
you're modeling your data for a backend
engineer when you want to test all those
changes then you want to see how the
user interactions will look like
basically for testing purposes in
development environments you want to put
some test data into your database so
that you have something to test with
before you deploy whatever changes that
you made in the database for that
purpose we have a concept called as
seeding and seeding basically means you
write some script usually you create
another migration or you can put it in
the same migration also but the best
practices say you create different
migration file for seeding data seing
test data test data into your database
and it's called sitting basically seting
means putting some test data into your
database for testing purposes in
development environments so let's create
another migration file with the command
dbate new seat data SE data and when you
press enter it creates another file
called the time stamp stamp and the seat
data because this time stamp is greater
than the previous one these will be
sequentially arranged and now this is
end empty what I'll do is I'll again
paste some SQL statements to save some
time then we can go through what's
happening there how we are inserting the
data for seeding purposes these are all
the SQL queries using which we are
putting some test data into our database
into our tables so there is nothing
special here basic SQL queries if you
have already explored the basics of SQL
the basics of postgress they'll you
understand it if you not then please do
it it'll make understanding this video
much easier so what we doing we are
using a CT also called as common table
expression to make it more readable so
we are creating an intermediate table
called inserted users and in that we are
inserting some test data into the users
table taking some sample emails some
names some password hashes and we're
inserting it and we returning two fields
for this SQL query execution the IDS and
the emails of the inserted users and we
are taking that and this is an
intermediate tib called inserted
profiles what we are doing here is we're
taking the inserted users table and
using this from inserted users we are
doing select select the ID of the user
and we putting the image since the
Avatar URL you have mentioned here we
are putting some static image URL and
for the bio we are doing a case wi so if
email is something like this then put
this bio if email is something like this
then put this bio for this put this bio
otherwise put some logic to put
different different bios for different
different users then for the phone field
we are just inserting some random phone
number then moving on same way we are
inserting some project
and etc etc using SQL queries just
normal CD so let's go ahead and apply
these migrations on our database so that
we have some data to test with for
applying the migrations we can do dmate
up and we do it it applies seeds all the
data into our database and we can go to
our tool and we can open any table so as
you can see projects has some entries
you can
click on a row projects project members
users all the tables have some some
entries and you can check the entries of
the table for users we have this ID this
email this full name password hash for
the second user we have these entries
when you go to user profiles we have
this user ID after URL bio for the
second user this is the BIOS third user
this is the bio etc etc like same way we
also have projects right so our CD is
successful and we have some data so that
we can start testing now now let's say
we have created the tables we have done
some seeding and now we want to build
some apis for the first API that you
want to build is you want to fetch the
list of all users and you want to send
it to the front end for that we can
write a simple query and do select from
users and we can execute this and we'll
get all the entries right the all the
users that exist in the users table now
what you want to do is for each user we
also want to send the profile
information which is on a different
table right we have the user profiles
table so for each user we want to fetch
the profile information from the user
profiles table and you want to embed
that into the user row and you want to
send it to the front end in a single API
call we use we don't want the user to
make a different call for fetching the
profile information that's why we are
embedding the profile information before
we send it so let's write the query for
that usually when we write SQL queries
always start from from section right
instead of the select section so that
you know exactly where you are drawing
your data from so we write from
users you and this is called an Alas and
assigning an alas usually a one letter
or two letter alas to a particular table
name inside an SQL query makes it more
convenient to refer to that table again
and again in that query right that's why
we use Al SS now from users table we
want the information of the user next
thing what we want is we want user's
profile information which is in a
different table okay and it is in the
user profiles table now the thing that
connects these two tables as you already
know is the foreign key so each user
profile entry each row in the user
profiles table has a field called user
ID which is a foreign key which refers
to the primary key of the user table so
what we can do we can use the join
operation to join the users table with
the user profiles table on a condition
which is the user ID should be the same
okay and to write that we can say left
join and the reason we are using left
join is because for some reason if the
user profile in the user profiles table
there is not an entry for a particular
user okay it is possible in our in our
backend system it is possible that the
user has never edited their user profile
that's why we have never created an
entry for them in the user profiles
table so in these situations if we go
with inner join we will get an mty
result because what inner join does each
condition for a particular condition
there should be an entry for both the
tables okay since in this case we want
the user information in any case right
in any case does not matter whether they
have the profile information in the user
profiles table or not but we want the
user information anyway that's the
reason we are going with left joint so
that even if there isn't an entry in the
user profiles table we'll still get the
value of the users information from the
users table okay that's the logic behind
going with left joint and most of the
times we'll be using inner joints and
left joints then we are writing SQ
queries those are the mostly used joints
you want to join with the user profiles
table and we'll name it alas up and the
condition for the joining is on the join
condition is u. ID the ID field in the
users table should be the same as the
user ID field in the user profile table
this is the condition okay this is the
condition on which we are joining both
these tables now we know where we are
drawing our data from okay we have
joined two tables we have an join table
and now what we can do we can select in
the select phase we'll see what are the
data that we want to fetch now that we
know where we are drawing our data from
we'll see what data we are drawing from
what we'll do we want to fetch
everything from the user R so we'll say
U do star comma we want to add another
field in each row called profile okay so
for that field what you want you want
the corresponding Row from the user
profiles table and you want to convert
it into a Json and we want to embed it
into a field in the user row called as
profile okay for that what we can do we
write 2 Json B which basically converts
a particular row into a Json it is a
inbu function provided by pogress and we
can use that to convert it and we can
write take up. STAR which means take the
corresponding Row from the user profiles
table convert it into a Json and name it
as profile before returning okay we have
our query now now let's try running it
okay and when we run it let's see what
the data looks like and this is what the
data looks like we have all the fields
from the users table we have ID email
full name password hash created at
updated that and we have an extra field
called profile which is a Json and that
has all the information from the user
profiles table okay now using this query
in a single API we can send the users
data and the user profile data from a
single database call okay using joints
another thing to notice here is whatever
data whenever we run a particular query
in any relational data the data that we
get returned is in a random format they
don't follow any particular format so
because of that whenever we run a select
query whenever we are returning a list
of data points into our front end we
have to sort it by default using some
column and usually what we do we sort it
by the
created it column because we want to
return the data in the reverse order of
when they were created so that the user
can see all the latest users so for that
what you can write order by U do created
at you want to take the created at field
from the users table and we want to sort
by that and we want to sort by
descending because we want the latest
entries and when you do that and run it
we get all the users in the reverse
order of how or when they were created
okay and this is what the query for an
API of get all users looks like so if we
have an AP something like this
slv1 SL users if we have an endpoint
which is a get endpoint our backend can
use a query like this a database query
like this to return all the data to the
user of course there will be other
processing that will happen this the
serialization Der serialization
depending on what language that you are
using if you're using something like
JavaScript or typescript or nodejs then
the serialization overhead is not that
much but if you're using something like
go then it has to deserialize into its
own struct then that struct will be sent
by serializing into a Json format before
it gets sent over the Internet to our
front end right this is what a typical
get all users endpoint looks like now
let's see another end point which is
something like slv1 SL users SL a
particular user ID okay so we'll write
it as user ID we'll get it as a dynamic
parameter in our API and we can pass
that user ID to our database query as a
parameterized query we'll see what
parameterized query means but if you
don't understand this part please was
the previous video where we have done a
deep dive on API designing and what are
Dynamic parameters how we design these
API end points etc etc so let's jump on
what this query will look like catching
the information the profile information
and the user information of a particular
user given a user ID from our Dynamic
parameter before we get into that let
understand what is a
parameterized queries parameterized
query is basically a safety mechanism
provided by databases which basically
means before running a query you can
provide a particular slot can provide a
particular slot and you tell the
database that this is your query and at
this position there is an empty slot but
before I execute this query I will
provide the information in this slot now
the catch is whatever information I
provide here it will be a string you can
cannot pass it you cannot pass it to
render it as a database action call
right it will just be a string so if
someone passes something very dangerous
like so we have a query and inside the
slot if you pass like let's say delete
from users a query which deletes
everything deletes all the users in the
database that will not be considered as
a SQL query because the way
parameterized query works is whatever
you pass in this slot they are
considered as a string okay they are
escaped in the technical term and it is
a safety mechanism to avoid situations
avoid vulnerabilities like SQL injection
where if you are constructing your query
instead of using parameters you are
constructing by concatenating Different
Different Strings you constructing your
SQL query instead of using parameters
then you can be a victim to SQL
injection okay so this is a very
important concept you can do your own
research to understand how SQ injection
Works etc etc but to simplify everything
whenever you have a dynamic value in
this case we want to fetch the
information of a single user using the
ID of that user so the ID of the user is
the dynamic value here so what we want
to do we want to keep a particular slot
in our query and we tell the database
that when we run this query we are going
to provide the ID of the user but for
now it is just an empty slot and when we
provide the ID it will it should just be
considered as an user's ID just a simple
string nothing else no more power should
be given to this particular string okay
that's the use of parameterized query it
makes your query more secure to execute
and most of the times whatever database
driver whatever library that you are
using whether in nodejs or go rust
python whatever it is your database
driver your OM they have capabilities to
handle all these slots with parameters
and etc etc since we are not getting
into code or any specific programming
language here we'll be looking at how
parameters work in the SQL editor itself
fortunately the this table plus the
software that we are using to write our
queries and to see our results etc etc
they are providing an interface to
provide parameters to our query so we
can see how it works but in real world
when you're actually building backend
you'll handle parameters using your
library using your driver whatever
driver that you are using okay with that
let's write our query to get the
information of a single user for that we
don't really need to change much we
still want all the information of the
user from the users table we still want
all the information of the user from the
profiles table using this Json
conversion the only thing that will
change is we want to filter by users's
ID when a single users information now
for that we want to add a where clause
and write where users ID u. ID is equals
to a parameter so this is where we are
assigning a slot an empty slot we are
telling that this is the name of the
variable is called user ID and this is
the whole query and we are saying that
this is the query and this is an empty
slot and when we run this query we'll
provide you the value of this slot so
that you can do your comparison and show
us the results so let's run this and we
are shown this dialogue so that we can
pass the actual value of the user ID but
as I said in your actual backend
environment you'll be handling this in
code in your particular driver or
Library so for this let's let wrap this
we have to wrap it in single codes right
all the strings in SQL have to be
wrapped in single code to be interpreted
as strings that's why we are wrapping it
in string and we are pasting The UU ID
of the user okay this is the U ID I have
pasted it here and then let's run this
and when we run this we get the
information of a single user and you can
check this is the user ID we still
getting all the information from the
users table and we're still getting all
the information from the profile table
but in this case we are only getting the
information of a single user using our
parameters with the same query so this
if you remember was for the endpoint V1
SL users SL colon user ID so ideally
while routing when the front makes the
API call with the appropriate U ID value
this will be routed to your particular
Handler the Handler will pass it to your
service the service will pass it to a
repository and it will pass the user ID
the actual U ID you'll take the U ID and
you pass it in the appropriate parameter
using the slot thing that I mentioned
and after you get this result you'll get
the result like this and this will get
serialized and transferred over to the
friend end in Json format going back to
the get all users API the get all users
query what if we want to provide some
Dynamic filters or some Dynamic sorts
usually in apis like these where we
fetch an array of entities like get all
users get all projects get all task in
the same API we also have to support
some kind of dynamic sorting or some
kind of dynamic filtering or both at the
same time now the problem is without you
using these queries without constructing
these queries in a proper orm or using a
programming language constructing the
SQL query
ourselves showing that part of the
mechanism in a SQL editor is a little
difficult but we can imagine how the
query might get constructed in an actual
programming language when we are
actually writing our backend code and we
can focus on just the SQL query part
without focusing too much on how we are
going to construct the query so if you
want to go back to the earlier query
which was get all users so when we
remove the Weare clause and when we run
this we're getting all the list of all
the users just as we had before now we
want to add some Dynamic sorts and some
Dynamic filters now let's see what all
fields we have in the users table we
have ID email full name password hash
let's say we want to add a filter
condition and we want to filter by the
name and our condition will be we will
pass a first letter of the name and we
want to return all those users who have
the first letter add that particular
letter whatever the front end is passing
that is going to be our filter condition
and for sort we want to take the sort
order from the user and we want to take
this field by which the user wants to
sort the result okay and as I said it's
a little difficult showing how the quer
is going to be constructed because what
happens in an actual backend is let's
say this is our query this is our query
payload and it's say p generated query
right so user can send these all query
parameters they can send a page query
parameter if they don't send it by
default we are going to set pages one
same way they are going to send a limit
parameter if they don't send it we set
it as something like 10 or 20 whatever
makes sense in your use case then we
come to the filtering part so as I said
for the filter we want to filter by the
first letter of the name so let's say we
take a query parameter called letter and
if they don't pass it then in this case
we don't set any default if they don't
pass it then we set it as null or in an
actual backend system we don't include
this in our query itself okay when they
constructing our query dynamically we
check that if the user has passed this
query parameter or not if they have pass
we include it in the we Clause if they
have not then we don't include it at all
okay that's how we do it in an actual
backing system same way we check the
sort conditions now the first thing is
we want to check let's say sort by you
check if this query parameter is present
or not if this is present then we
consider that as a sorting parameter
usually we don't allow the user to pass
any field as sort parameters uh we give
them some options that you can either
pass let's say full name or by email or
by created ad okay we give them some
options some fields from the table that
we allow user to pass and depending on
that we give them the result and the
last thing that we allow them is sort
order what is the order that you want
your results in whether it is ascending
order or descending order now for these
two Fields what we do we check if the
user has passed a sord by parameter then
we need consider that for the Sorting
mechanism if they have not by default we
take creat at as the default sorting
parameter same way we check if they have
passed sort order or not if they have we
consider whether it is ascending or
descending if they have not by default
we take descending so if the user has
not passed any of this what do we end up
with we end up with these query
parameters by default we set the pages
one limit as 10 sld by created at and
order by descending right by default we
anyway give them results as per this but
we also give them the option to
customize how they want the results
right now with that let's see how we can
construct the query we have our filter
which we are considering as the first
letter of the name we have our sort and
we allow them to sort by email or full
name or create at and we also uh want to
pigate this since it is a list of all
users whenever we are creating list apis
we should most of the time try to pigate
it unless we have a particular reason we
have a particular user interface where
we don't want to Pigeon it but most of
the time we should pigeon it okay now
going back to our query we have this
normal query now what we want to do we
want to add some more capabilities to
this so the first thing is we want to
add the filter condition you want to
give users the ability to filter by the
first letter of the name of the user so
what we can do we say where U do full
name I like I like means the SQL
operator like but it is case insensitive
so it does not matter is upper case or
lower case it will still try to match
the pattern okay I like and inside this
what we do we pass a parameterized query
and the parameterized query will be say
letter okay then we concatenate with
let's say the percentage sign let's run
this query and let's provide the letter
G and let's run this and we are getting
two results because these two users have
the first letter of the name starting
with J that's why we're getting these
two results now let's try to run this
with another letter let's say x for this
we don't get any results because we
don't have any users who have names
starting with x same way if we try to
run it with something like a we get the
user Alice Brown right so the filter
part is working as expected and for
those uh who are not familiar with the
basics of SQL what this we are doing is
we are taking the parameterized query
whatever is coming from the front end
and we are concat erating that with this
symbol this percentage symbol what this
means is take the letter whatever the
first letter is so if we pass J this is
what happens J and the percentage symbol
and this goes to the I like pattern
matching so what we're saying give us
all the names which is starting with the
letter j but we don't care whatever
comes after that okay that's the reason
we are getting all the users who have
the first letter with J okay now we have
our filter condition implemented let's
go ahead and Implement our sort
conditions so as you can see we are
adding the default sort condition
created at descending here now what we
want to do we want to make it Dynamic so
we want to say order by this is a
parameterized query we want to say Do by
and as order we also want to make it a
parameter they're saying sort order okay
we have our sort conditions let's check
this and we have three parameters to
fill now so let's provide it as J and
for the sort by in the back end we have
to construct this parameter in a way
that it matches the existing query since
we are using Al SS in our existing query
we have to provide the sort condition in
the same way what we want to do we want
to sort by the emails of the user so so
the parameter we should pass is U do
email right because we have to match the
alas that is existing in this query same
way sort order we want to say descending
and let's run this and we are getting
two results John do and Jan Smith and
this is how it is sorted John comes
first then comes Jan so let's try to run
this again but this time make it
ascending now Jane comes first and John
gum second so our sort conditions are
also working as expected now the last
thing we also want to pigate this query
since it is a list of all users we want
to pigate this query now in the end we
can write the user is trying to fetch
page one we have page and limit for the
concept of page if you want to fetch the
first page in the query we have to add
something like offset it and we want to
take also a parameter for here so we
write page page range you want page now
the second thing is we also want to take
the limit and for the limit we also take
a limit parameter and now let's run this
we have two more parameters for now we
want page as zero now in the actual back
end the user will pass pages from one to
whatever the maximum amount and we are
setting also the page number is one but
since we we are talking about the actual
database query here we have to pass the
first page as zero right the offset
starts from zero that's how we want to
differentiate between the actual
database query and whatever is set for
the experience of the user the we want
to start from the offset zero then the
limit is one since we are only getting
two results for this query we want to
check if the pation is working as
expected or not that's why we are
setting the limit is one and when we are
run this we getting Jan myth as the
first result and when we try to run this
again but this time we wanton page the
second page in the backend concept it is
the page two and in the database concept
it is offset one and when we run this we
getting job okay so the page ination
concept is also working and as I
mentioned these things will change a
fair amount when you are actually
writing the EXL query in your back end
because you have to construct all these
queries dynamically you using your
programming language but to understand
what happens at the database level this
example is pretty much enough so far we
have seen what the database query looks
like for this API get all users and this
API get a single user now let's proceed
to creating a user which is post / aa/
users let's see what the query for this
will look like now if you're already
familiar with SQL basics this is a
simple insert operation what we want to
do is want to do an insert call insert
into users you want to insert into users
table and what are the columns that we
are passing we are passing email and
full name and the password hash which
we'll create in our backend code but for
the sake of this example we are just
passing the password hash second we want
to pass the actual values and let's use
parameterized queries here for
email then for name and then for
password and this this camel case
password hash and in the end we want to
return what all users that were created
using this query for that we can do
returning Stu so return all the users
all the rows that were created using
this query so let's try to run this we
have to pass all the parameters and in
single codes since these are all strings
right so for email we can do something
like test at
gmail.com and for the full name we can
do test test and for the password any
random stream right for the sake of this
example then let's run this and we run
it we are getting a single row as a
result because we are doing returning
star and we just created one user we are
getting a single user entry a new user
was created and we're getting all the
information for that user and when we go
to the users table we can see that a new
user with test at gmail.com is created
and is in the table okay okay and this
is corresponding to the post / API SL
users API since we are creating a user
so we did a insert operation and created
a user and return the response in this
API next now let's get to update a user
now going back let's go to our query
editor minimize this now as I mentioned
before in our actual backend code we
will be constructing these SQL queries
dynamically depending on what are the
parameters that is passed from the user
okay so for the for the update API what
the API usually looks like is it is a
patch API
and we are giving the user to update
certain properties of their profile okay
we are trying to update the user
profiles table and we are giving the
user a form some kind of form in the UI
to update their profile so they can
update their bio they can update their
phone number or they can update their
image URL in the field Avatar URL for
this we want to make the payload partial
and by that I mean they can pass either
all the three fields or they can pass a
single field but depending on what are
the fields they are passing we only have
to update that field for all the other
fields we don't touch that okay so in
the programming language depending on
what you're using we check what are the
fields that the user has passed and from
a set of allowed Fields so let's say we
check if bio is present then take the
latest entry what the user has passed
the latest value of bio and update that
in the database same way we check if the
phone number is passed update it but
Avatar URL is not passed then don't
touch it keep it the same okay so with
that understanding going back to our SQL
query editor what query we can write is
after going through our backend code we
have seen that the user has only passed
bio and phone number so this is what the
query is going to look like after
getting constructed okay we say update
user
profiles then set bio equals to this is
going to a
parameterized query bio equals to bio
comma they have also passed phone number
and phone equals to phone we're going to
pass these values in our parameterized
queries and we also have to pass for
which user we want to update uh usually
we'll take this as a dynamic parameter
from the URL as as you can see here
we're taking the ID of the user from the
URL so that's what we will pass in our
database right and we want to update the
information the profile information of a
single user right so we have to pass
that in our parameterized query for that
we can write where user ID which is a
field in the user profiles table equals
to a parameter called user ID and in the
end we are saying whatever row that you
have updated return the latest value of
that row and then let's run this and for
Bio we are seeing updated bio for phone
number we passing a new phone number and
we run this and when you check it you
can see the bio is updated and the phone
number is also updated this particular
user and that's how an update user API
will look like now I want to show
something else if you notice here we
have a field called updated at and the
purpose of keeping this field in a table
is every time a particular row is
updated we also have to update this
field corresponding to that row to the
current time stamp the time stamp when
the row was updated and if we check the
field this is same as the created it
this is the same as when the user was
first created it is not updated since we
just updated the value uh right now this
should have the current time stamp which
it is not now usually there are two ways
of achieving this first is the manual
way every time you are doing an update
operation you can explicitly set the
value of updated column to the current
time Stam using your application code
you can pass another parameterized query
and you can say updated at equals to
updated at okay you can do that or you
can use another feature of databases
called trigger
and what triggers do is you can set a
particular condition and when that
condition is met you can perform some
action that's the whole idea of using
triggers at database levels so what we
are trying to do here is we will set up
a workflow using which what will say is
every time we are updating a particular
Row in any table we want to set the
updated at field of that row to the
latest time stamp using triggers okay we
want to make that change so that we
don't have to manually change the
updated at field every time we update
the information of a particular user
okay for that we have to write another
migration that is one change that we
want to make the second thing that you
should know about which is very
important concept is indexes or indices
what is database indexes is right this
is a very important concept and it
affects the performance of your queries
a lot okay so we have to understand what
is indexing and we have to implement it
in our own database using a migration
now let's understand what indexing is in
the first place so going back to our
earlier query so if we go to the history
tab here and let's check what was
earlier query so let's say this one okay
and let me close this and on this this
one right there is a select query for
for the list of all users okay and if
you notice here we are using some
conditions here let's try to find out
what are conditions that we are using
the first thing that you notice is we
are joining with another table and here
we are saying the ID of the users table
should be same as the user ID in the
user profiles table this is the join
condition here and it is an equality
condition okay same way another thing
that we are doing here is we are sorting
by the email field in the users table
and we are sorting in the order of
ascending this second thing to notice
and I'll explain why we are drawing
attention to this part right now these
are the two things now coming back to
what are database indexes index is
basically means by the normal definition
if you are familiar with the index
section of a book so we Google it let's
say book index this is a typical index
section of any book and what we see here
is the writer of the book or whoever the
publisher is they have created an index
section where we they are saying you can
find chapter one starting from page it
and and chapter 2 starting from page 29
chapter 3 starting from page
35 etc etc right all the chapters are
given here and the corresponding page
number where you will find the starting
of that chapter and because of this
index section if someone wants to
directly skip to chapter 4 they don't
have to open the book and they don't
have to go Page by page page by Page
let's say the book has around so it says
82 let's say the book has around 100
pages
so to find the chapter
4 the user does not have to go through
50 pages one by one in order to reach
chapter 4 just to find the location of
the chapter 4 they don't have to
manually scheme through 50 pages just
for the sake of finding the location of
a certain page right they can directly
refer to the index they can see that
chapter 4 starts from page 54 and they
can directly jump to page 54
right in the same way when we are
talking about
databases going back to our earlier
tables this is the task table we have a
bunch of tasks and every task has a
single ID right and we can see all the
results in this particular format
because it is a software which fetches
all the rows from our database and shows
us in a sequential manner but when the
database stores our data it is not in a
sequential manner right every entry in a
row might be somewhere else since in the
earlier part of this video we have
discussed that the databases that we are
talking about relational or non
relational these are disk based
databases which means the database takes
our data and stores it somewhere in the
disk somewhere right it can be anywhere
in a very efficient format it follows a
lot of algorithms a lot of complex
systems goes behind where to store which
data etc etc but on a very high level on
a very simple way of understanding we
can assume that each row is stored
somewhere in the disk right if we have a
query where we want to find out the
information of this particular task with
this particular ID which we can pass in
a parameterized query and you want to
fet the information of this particular
task what is the Brute Force without
thinking about indexes what is the Brute
Force way the database system has a
bunch of tasks and it has has stored all
the task in different different
locations right in in a physical hard
disk when it gets a query which says
that we want the information of this
particular task what it has to do it has
to go through all the task one by one to
find out if the ID matches this if the
ID matches this if the ID matches this
etc etc and finally when it reaches this
ID okay it it has a match it can see
that the ID that we have passed it
accurately matches this particular ID
and then what it does it Returns the
information of this particular ID to us
and we have our result now what happened
is we sent a query the database did a
sequential scan okay it went through all
the tasks one by one in different
different locations of the disk as I
said the database system has a very
complex way of storing the data in
database right and it when it went to
all those locations and it checked
whether the ID matches this item whether
the ID matches this item etc etc and
until at the end it found a match and it
returned the information which as you
can already see is a very tedious and a
very time-taking and a very inefficient
solution okay now since we only have
around six entries in this table it
might not seem a lot uh it is a lot fast
but imagine if we had add a, entries or
a million entries or a billion entries
in the table then going through all
those items one by one and checking from
different different locations of the
disk can take a lot of time and can make
the query very inefficient so for that
purpose what the database offers is a
feature called index what index does in
the same way a book index gives us all
the page numbers for a particular
chapter if you want chapter 4 we can
directly see that it starts from page 28
same way on a very high level not to go
into the technical Deep dive of how
indexes work how B tree Works etc etc
which you can do your own research for
but just for understanding the Practical
purpose of index why we use indexes for
each ID so we'll understand how index is
actually implemented practically but for
each ID so we can index a particular
field of a particular table let's say if
we index by ID so what an index contains
is for each ID you have the location
here okay for each ID like this okay for
each ID from here for each ID it has an
table for each ID it has the
corresponding
location of the row right where exactly
in the disk in the hard disk the
information of this particular task is
stored
so it has another table a lookup table
where it stores the ID of the task and
the location of the task same the ID of
the second task location of the second
task etc etc now that it has an index
like this when it gets a query which
says that we want the information of
this particular task what it does
instead of looking through all the items
all the tasks in the disk from different
different locations one by one what it
does it refers to the index it tries to
check whether this exists in the index
or not so as you can see the index is a
direct access it is not stored in
different different parts of the disk it
is stored at one place in sequentially
so it does it is very fast to go through
all the entries so it checks whether it
matches the first one the second one the
third one the fourth one the fifth one
and it finally finds that this entry so
it is somewhere here this one matches it
so it directly finds this entry in a
very short time and in the corresponding
lookup value it finds the location where
exactly the information for this task is
stored in the hard disk and it gets the
location goes to that location directly
and returns whatever value is stored in
that location directly to our user
whoever made the database query in the
first place now as you can see compared
to the previous operation which was a
sequential lookup going through
different different locations across the
hard disk and trying to find out whether
the ID that we have passed matches the
current ID or not etc etc and finally
return the result as compared to this
approach where we have a lookup table
where we are storing the ID of each item
and the location of that item okay and
we are directly giving the result of
that to the user and that is the purpose
of index index is basically a lookup
table you can imagine it as a lookup
table which has information for a
particular field and the location of the
particular Row for that field now that
is the first property of the index it
has a lookup table and it can directly
access whatever value that you have
passed from this table and it can find
the corresponding location of the entry
it can return you the result the second
property of the index is the order of
the index it can be either ascending it
can be descending so if you remember in
the previous query where we are saying
we want to return the list of all users
sorted by descending order right now for
that query to perform as efficiently as
possible because we have a requirement
like that what we can do first thing is
we want to create an index on created at
right we want to take the field instead
of ID we are taking the index created at
and we want to index that field so that
when we execute that query the database
can instantly find all the created at
fields and the corresponding Row for the
that created at field and it can return
it the second thing is because the sort
order is also in the picture we also
have to decide in what order we want to
index either ascending or descending or
both of them okay we can create
different different indices but it all
depends on our requirement so as you can
see by default we are returning the
descending order of creat De so when
creating the index we can say that we
want to create an index on the field
created at in the descending order so
that when we execute that query which
has order by created at and descending
the index can quickly go through all the
created at field that is already ordered
in descending order and it can quickly
return that result instead of if it had
all the creat FI in ascending order then
it will have to go through all of that
and you have to rearrange and do a sort
and then return right depend depending
on our requirement we can customize the
behavior of the indices okay that's a
very high level introduction to indices
so what you have to remember is every
time you are using a wear clause or a
join condition and depending on what is
the frequency that you are doing that
but is the frequency that you're doing
the join condition or the we Clause you
can decide to create an index on that
condition so that the subsequent queries
are faster because how the database does
the lookup so the two two things that we
saw one thing is we have to create
trigger so that the updated at field is
automatically updated every time we
update a particular row of the user
second is we have to create indexes so
that the join conditions and the wear
Clauses and the Sorting conditions are
faster okay so let's go ahead and create
a migration which covers all these I
have gone ahead and created a new
migration file using dbate and pasted
all the uh index create statements and
the trigger statement so let's go
through and understand what's Happening
Here what are we exactly doing here so
in the first section you can see in the
up migrations we are creating a bunch of
indices the first one we are creating an
index on the email field in the users
table because we have let's imagine we
have an API where we have to find a
particular user by the email or we have
a database query we where we are joining
the users table with the task table
depending on the email of the user right
in the join condition we have the
condition where we are matching the
email because we have a requirement like
that we decided that we want to index
the email field of the users table so
that in join conditions and in the wear
Clause we can quickly find the
corresponding user given a particular
email using the index and that was the
reasoning behind using email or index
ing email from the users table so this
is the syntax looks like this is a
generic SQL syntax same way we are
creating an index on the created field
for the users table in descending order
because if you remember the select query
the get all users API where we are by
default returning all the users sorted
by the created field in descending order
since we have an API like that and it is
pretty free frequently called that's the
reason we want to optimize the query
execution of that particular database
query by creating an index on the
created at field in the descending order
so that the database can do a fetch
operation very fast as compared to FH
operation without using indices okay
same way for the task table we are
creating an index on the project ID so
if you remember going back to our first
migration where we created the table we
have the task table and we have project
ID here okay and this is a foreign key
so imagine we have an API where we are
fetching all the tasks of a particular
project right and for that APA we have
to create a database query where we have
to take the projects table and we have
to join it we have to left join it with
the task table depending on the it ID
field of the project table and the
project ID field in the task table that
is going to be our join condition right
these two has to match now as I said
that whatever field is involved in your
join conditions or in your wear Clause
if you index that field that operation
is going to be much faster now by
default whatever field is the primary
key of the table that is by default
automatically indexed by your database
right you don't have to manually do it
so in the join condition two fields are
involved the ID field and the project ID
field from Project table and the task
table so since ID field is the primary
key in the projects table we don't have
to think about this this is
automatically indexed by the database
but in the task table we have the field
project ID is is a foreign key and this
is involved in the join condition and
since it is involved in the join
condition we want to index it because it
is not index by default since it is a
foreign key it is not the primary key in
this table so that is the reasoning
behind indexing in this migration we are
creating an index on the project ID
field on the task table because we have
a join condition where we want to fetch
all the task of a particular project
right for that we have to make a left
join in the left join we we have a
condition where we are matching by the
project ID and that's the reason we want
to make that operation little faster
that's why we are indexing by project ID
field in the task table same way in the
task table we have an assigned to okay
this is also a foreign key so imagine
another API where we want to fetch all
the task of a particular user so this
assigned to is a foreign key which
references the users table so this will
have a corresponding entry in the user
table with ID of that user right so to
implement that a what we have to do we
have to take
the users table and we have to join it
with the task table on the condition
that assign to has to match users. ID
right since ID is the primary key of the
users table we don't have to think about
that but in this table assign two is a
foreign key right so we have to Index
this field to make the join operation of
joining users table with task table a
little faster that's why we are creating
an index on the assigned to field in the
task table okay next we are creating an
index on the created at field in
descending order in the task field
because the same reasoning if you want
to return the list of all tasks to show
it on our front end by default the API
returns all the tasks sorted by the
created at field in descending order
because we want to return all the latest
tasks and we can fetch all the latest
task by sorting all the tasks in
descending order and to fetch all the
tasks in descending order to make that
operation a little faster we are
creating an index on the created it
field in the task table in descending
order right same way we are creating an
index on the status field because in the
get all tasks API let's say we have a
filter condition in the filter condition
what we are doing we want to fetch all
tasks so if we go to task status we are
creating an custom ENT type and we have
four types of status pending in progress
completed and cancelled now let's
imagine in the get all tasks API we want
to fetch all tasks which have the status
pending okay we have a requirement like
that and the front end the user can pass
any Dynamic status right the pending
progress completed whatever right and we
want to quickly fetch all the tasks
depending on what is the status of the
task and because the status field was
involved in a wear Clause what is the
condition for creating an index or what
is the thumb rule if that field is
involved in join condition or in a wear
clause or in a sort condition okay these
three are your primary guidance on when
you should consider creating an index
for that field okay since status field
is used in a Weare Clause we can
consider creating index on the status
field in the task table now another
thing is you should not create an index
right away whenever you have a condition
that field is used in a we clause or a
join condition or a s by you have to see
and you have to evaluate how frequently
that query is being called or if the
performance trade-off is worth it or not
since to maintain an index the database
at all times has to take that field
let's say you have the project ID field
in the task table project ID and in the
lookup we have all the locations of the
task right we have all these entries to
maintain this index to have the latest
state of all the tasks in that index
what the database has to do every time
you do an insert task or every time you
do an update task this index has to be
accurately maintained and to maintain
that every time you do an insert or
update the database has to do some kind
of operation to store the latest state
of the task in the index
table right and which adds some kind of
overhead some kind of overhead even
though it is not a lot and it depends
what is the size of your database how
many entries you have in your database
index operations them CS can add some
kind of overhead so as a backend
engineer you have to evaluate these
conditions that whether creating an
index is worth it or not whether the
overhead of maintaining an index IND is
worth it or not and that depends on how
frequently your database query is
executed and what kind of user
experience that you want to provide at a
tri you have to consider a lot of
parameters but on a very high level
without thinking about all this micro
optimizations you can take these three
parameters that whether that field is
involved in a join condition or a wear
clause or a sort operation if it is and
you see that that query is frequently
called then you can go ahead and create
an index on that
and if you in the future you see that
that query is not being frequently
called then you can just go ahead and
delete that Index right okay but as a
start you can consider creating it and
monitoring your performance etc etc same
way we are creating an index for project
I in Project members we are creating an
index on user ID in Project members etc
etc right the same logic the same kind
of reasoning applies everywhere okay
that's pretty much all about index now
coming to the triggers part as I said we
want to automate the operation of every
time we update a particular Row in any
table we also want to update the updated
field of that row so that we don't have
to do it manually from our application
code for that what we are doing we are
creating a function in postgress we have
the ability to create custom functions
and we are creating a function and we
are naming it something and we are
seeing it returns a trigger and we are
starting a transaction okay and what we
are saying is take the row and the
updated field of that row and update it
to the current time stamp and return the
new row whatever with the new value of
the updated field and now we have a
custom function that is ready to use
okay next what we are doing we are
creating Triggers on different different
tables right we are taking all the
different different tables users user
profiles project tasks and we are
creating Triggers on each table what we
doing we are naming the trigger
something so that it is easier to drop
the trigger later on in in our down
migrations okay and what you are doing
you're saying every time we are doing
some kind of update operations on this
table go to that row whatever row is
updated in that operation and execute
this function and what this function
does it takes the updated field and sets
it to the current time stamp okay and
with that setup what happens every time
we do an update operation this will
automatically update the updated at
field for that r okay now that's pretty
much it we are creating triggers for all
the tables and in the down migrations we
are deleting all the triggers we're
deleting the function and we're deleting
all the
indexes that we created then we can go
ahead and execute these migrations for
that we can do dbate up and this is
applied now going back to our table plus
let's do that update operation again
right so we remove this this this was
our earlier update operation right and
let's execute this say updated bio 3
okay and let's apply it and go to this
Row And now when you see the updated at
field you can see that this is the
current time when I am recording this
video and this is the current date and
time the time stem accurately matches so
our trigger accurately worked right we
did some kind of oper update operation
on this particular row and this field is
automatically updated and that's the use
of triggers now with that we have
created database queries for all these
apis okay now going through each of
these apis and creating a database query
is going to take a lot of time at least
a few hours more and I don't want to
make this video longer than what it
already is so you can go ahead and with
all the uh reasoning that I have
explained here and all the SQL Basics
and the postgress basics that you have
already learned you can go ahead and
create the database queries for all
these apis right and you can see how the
join conditions work how the indexes are
coming into place how the triggers are
working etc etc etc right and that's
pretty much all you need to know and of
course that's not all you need to know
but that's pretty much 80% of what you
are going to be doing as a backend
engineer while you are dealing with
databases okay you're going to take apis
and you're going to analyze what all
payload is coming from the user and you
have to construct a dynamic query
depending on that you have to use
parameterized queries to securely pass
whatever user value that you have and
you have to execute that query and you
have to return the data right that's a
very high level work through of what
you're going to be doing as a backend
engineer when it comes to databases of
course there are a lot of other things
but this pretty much covers on a very
high level the most of the things that
you'll be doing